hi I am Tammy Pao Mason and we are here
today to take a tour of my brother Randy
Pausch his room welcome to his childhood
room in his room we now have two beds
that look like twin beds they used to be
bunked a lower bunk and an upper bunk
and on the ends of these beds by the way
these beds were made by my father we
have playing cards because our family
was a huge player of cards we enjoyed
that very much
when these beds were bunked the pictures
below and above make a little more sense
in the lower bunk you were clearly under
the water notice the submarine Randy of
course was on the upper bunk and in the
upper bunk you have a piece here my
brother and Jack sheriff and I painted
this room there were a few things that
he specifically asked me to paint this
is one of them this is a scene of the
Chesapeake Bay he when he would sleep up
here was clearly above the water and in
this scene you will see some seagulls
you will see some buoys and you will see
our boat that boat my father bought it's
called the Gini Lynn one story about
Randy is that we would take turns
waterskiing and the rule was you got to
water-ski as long as you could stay
above the water and I would water-ski
for a while and then my arms would get
tired and I would let go Randy I was a
little bit of an athlete so when he
would get up we'd be going along not too
far from Sandy point and be waterskiing
and Randy still stayed up so my father
decided hmm I wonder what will happen if
I head directly all the way across by
the Chesapeake Bay Bridge across
Chesapeake Bay and sure enough
Randy held on the entire way across the
Chesapeake Bay and my father was amazed
and then it became almost a challenge of
could he
get Randy to drop off the skis so after
he'd gone all the way across the
Chesapeake Bay and Randy still holding
on he started doing figure eights and
after about the third or fourth figure
eight with all of the weight created by
the boat Randy eventually did drop off
as you look around the room you're going
to see a lot of kind of interesting
things kind of tongue-in-cheek and cute
one of my favorites is the footprints
going up the wall and being a great
person that wanted to defy gravity now
walking on the ceiling you see a black
hole and clearly whatever was walking
went into the hole oh dear over here in
the corner you see a rocket ship one of
the things that made a huge impression
on a lot of people our age was the
landing on the moon in 1969 Rainey and I
were in camp it was a sleepaway camp and
we both vividly remember one night when
we didn't have to go to bed on time we
got to go to the mess hall where they
had pulled in a small black and white
television and hundreds of kit little
kids staring at the screen watching the
grainy images of landing on the moon
this is Randy's capturing of his passion
for exploring and in this case exploring
of space and tied to that you see a
little green square in the ceiling and
that was the shortcut way the secret
passage to Venus over here in the room
you will see his Bureau and mirror and
we all remember the mirror mirror on the
wall who's the fairest of them all well
Randy had an answer to that he said
remember when I said you were the
fairest I lied when we were growing up
there was a young lady named Christie
Johnstone who just loved my brother and
was always thinking of incredibly
wonderful things to give him as tokens
of her care and affection for him Randy
and I grew up watching Star Trek with
Shatner and Leonard Nimoy and one of our
favorite episodes was the trouble with
tribbles well Christy found out how much
we loved Star Trek how much he loved
Star Trek and of course as we all know
he wanted to be Captain Kirk
she well before the advance of the
internet found a way to find and get him
his very own Tribble how I wish I had
that Tribble now another thing that she
did was find some personalized stickers
that have Randy's name on them and some
of these really do date the room
including the flying fickle finger award
which was a reference to the program
that we all watched called laughing one
of my favorites in here is vote
Randy above here is another piece that I
did that represented his love of chess
Randy learned to play chess my father
taught him and shortly after him he
really had become good at it and studied
it and read books about it and then
could beat my father my father decided
that he didn't want to play chess
anymore Randy loves chess so much that
he formed the chess team at our school
Oakland Mills High School he also
actually cast with an acrylic type of
substance chess pieces so when we were
working on the room he said tam I would
like you to create the night overtaking
the Queen and so I got the night piece
and I said the Queen piece and I was
like holding it up in different ways and
he said yes this is how I want you to do
it so I literally held the pieces and
painted it it's also a reflection of
important theme for our family is you
know rooting for the underdog and what
home would not be complete without the
quadratic equation on the wall it's an
equation that the math people clearly
love it just it's a beautiful beautiful
equation you've got a fraction
you've got exponents you've got square
root and you've got plus and minus you
got to love something like that and it
is literally front and center Randy was
a mathematician to the nth degree
he was brilliant and this reflects his
love of math over on the far side we see
a literature reference because Randy was
an avid reader as well and at the bottom
of Pandora's Box was hope loved it and
Jack Sheriff who was my Randy symbiotic
tits twin separated at Birth he was
almost my other brother he spent a lot
of time with our family and they were
very close could not resist when he was
working on the room he had to add Bob
Bob Hope as in Bob Hope the Entertainer
ah the elevator this was one of his
favorite creations you've got an UP
button you got a down button but clearly
it indicates that you're on the third
floor I think he thought about this
later and wondered maybe he should have
made it the sixth floor like the
penthouse I love this particular piece
he has written this backwards as if
someone was in the attic and writing a
message indicating help I'm trapped in
the Attic down over here you have one of
the things that was one of my favorites
of all three of my children when they
were little
beware of killer Mouse and there's the
mouse hole and just a little while ago
my youngest Makeda was in here and was
saying is there really a killer Mouse
mumma above his closet it says if you
smoke drink or use drugs
get out Randy really did live his life
in a very healthy way he exercised he
never smoked he never did drugs
occasionally would drink but rarely and
when the doctor told him to lose 10
pounds by golly he did
lid led a very very healthy life Jack
and Randy worked for Colombo's which was
a restaurant pizza place in Columbia and
their boss was named Neil Neil did not
care for disco music at all and so he
was always saying just go sucks so Randy
agreed so he put disco sucks on the wall
not long after mom and dad had the room
revealed to them
mom just quietly came with a white can
of paint and painted over the word sucks
because she viewed that that was an
inappropriate word to have above the
door frame where the words come against
in that's a nice friendly thing to see
as you're leaving it also be speaks
Randy's love of let's get together again
soon
and that was as true for friends as it
was for family and so I want to end this
tour and thank you for spending time
with me I hope you enjoyed it and take
care